[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un métier sur les
métiers scientifiques mais aussi une
formation pour devenir médecin
sans oublier notre rubrique consacrée
aux entreprises qui recrutent
sans plus tarder voici le sommaire les
métiers en rapport avec les sciences
sont nombreux une illustration avec
l'entreprise merkel la boîte heures et
le laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai tous deux sont situés sur le
territoire de saint françois en une
association c'est la santé pour devenir
médecin notamment une formation proposée
par l'ufr des sciences de la santé
simone veil à montigny le bretonneux
témoignages d'étudiants dans ce numéro
enfin si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises qui recrutent
trois offres proposées par l' agence
pôle emploi de guyancourt chercheurs
physicien et astronome ingénieurs elle
les métiers liés aux sciences sont
multiples et des professions d'ailleurs
bien présents sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines des centres de
recherche ou encore des entreprises
innovantes ils sont implantés
alors pour en savoir plus sur ces
métiers et bien je vous propose une
immersion au sein de l'entreprise merkel
la boîte heures et au sein du
laboratoire national de métrologie et
d'essai installé à guyancourt
l'entreprise merck la boîte heures est
une filiale du groupe pharmaceutique et
chimique merck le site de 5500 mètres
carrés accueille 230 salariés qui
travaillent sur le développement de
systèmes de purification d'eau
alors effectivement ici vous êtes au
centre mondial de recherches et
développement pour la boîte heures ce
sont les entreprises du monde entier qui
font appel à vos services
effectivement effectivement donc c'est
une activité extrêmement intéressante
parce que distribuer les produits
partout dans le monde génèrent
énormément de contraintes dans la
conception de nos produits
faut que ça marche partout il ya
différentes qualités de par le monde
différents réseaux électriques
c'est très complexe
[Musique]
béatrice programme bonjour bonjour est
ce que peut nous expliquer ce que vous
êtes en train de faire je réalise un
prélèvement d'eau sur les systèmes en
cours de développement
je vais réaliser ensuite des analyses de
chromatographie ionique avec ma collègue
laetitia et organique sur les dents le
laboratoire d'analysé de traces alors
esprit nous en dire un peu plus sur
votre parcours les études que vous avez
fait pour pour faire ce métier
oui donc j'ai obtenu une maîtrise de
chimie
organique
l'université de créteil à la suite de
quoi j'ai effectué des stages dans
différents laboratoires donc l'inra le
cnrs et j'ai travaillé dans un
laboratoire d'analysé agricole en
guadeloupe pendant quatre ans avant de
venir ici nous sommes à frappe c'est ici
qu est implanté le laboratoire national
de métrologie et d'essai plus connu sous
le nom de l est ne cet organisme a
plusieurs missions la métrologie
les essais mais aussi la certification
550 salariés travaillent sur ce site
[Musique]
thomas grenon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur général des duels n est alors
il existe en plusieurs implantations en
france et dans le monde mais ici
concrètement me fais quoi attraper
alors le lait ne est un établissement
public industriel et commercial
on va pouvoir travailler par exemple sur
tout ce qui est les nanotechnologies les
nanoparticules qui demandent des
installations extrêmement sophistiquée
et très pointu très précises
on va travailler sur tout ce qu'on
appelle la compatibilité
électromagnétique vous savez c'est les
ondes on est environné maintenant d'onde
avec le wifi tous les systèmes de
transmission on essaye de voir ce
qu'elles peuvent provoquer sur la santé
humaine comment elle se propage est ce
qu'elle ne ne se perturbent pas les unes
avec les autres on travaille par exemple
sur les compteurs linky
on a travaillé travaillé sur la
résistance au feu sur le fait que les
matériaux vont bien résister au feu
n'ont pas provoqué d'incendié on va
travailler sur tout ce qui est le
contact alimentaire aussi vérifier que
ce que l'on les emballages qu'on utilise
par exemple ne sont pas dangereux pour
la santé
[Musique]
nicolas faltot un bonjour bonjour est ce
qu'on va nous expliquer ce que vous êtes
en train de faire
alors là on est en train d'observer
d'analyser
des nanoparticules de dioxyde de titane
que l'on retrouve en fait sur ce swing
gum et qui lui donne sa couleur très
blanches qu'on fait c'est un colorant
blanc qu'on trouve dans beaucoup
d'aliments
c'est le e71 et donc notre travail c'est
d'observer et de mesurer
toutes ces nanoparticules pour essayer
de regarder donc la part
sur la population de particules qui est
comprise entre 1 et 100 nanomètres
alors vous vous êtes chercheur au
département matériaux sainte du hellen
quoi ça consiste votre métier
alors on a deux missions la première
mission c'est d'assurer la traçabilité
des mesures à l'échelle du nanomètre
on a conçu un instrument qui s'appelle
le microscope à force atomique
métrologique donc ça c'est une première
mission pis la deuxième c'est qu'on est
on est à un groupe de chercheurs on
essaie de comprendre les propriétés de
la matière à l'échelle nanométrique pour
mieux les mesurer
[Musique]
c'est un bac scientifique ensuite j'ai
poursuivi mes études à l'université en
physique puis j'ai continué par une
thèse
sur la supraconductivité projet
fait un stage post doctoral
au commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
j'ai été embauché au lait ne pourrait
être responsable de l'étalon de tension
geste c'est un métier aussi qui permet
ici de matière la traçabilité des unités
électriques
des métiers diversifiés c'est ce que
propose le laboratoire national de
métrologie et d'essai des métiers
scientifiques de haut niveau pour
lesquelles il faut aimer le travail en
équipe mais aussi être curieux et
réactif
là des métiers complexes vous l'avez vu
qui nécessitent des diplômes nous le
verrons d'ailleurs dans quelques minutes
mais avant je vous propose de nous
intéresser un autre domaine scientifique
la médecine grâce à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
étudiantes et les étudiants peuvent se
former à ce métier à montigny le
bretonneux
reportage inaugurée le 3 décembre 2012
l'ufr des sciences de la santé simone
veil implantée à montigny le bretonneux
porte le nom de l'ancien ministre de la
santé
elle accueille cette année cinq mille
six cents étudiants dont 942 première
année une première année commune aux
études de santé faisant partie du
premier cycle à l'issue les étudiants
passent en deuxième année choisiront
entre quatre filières médecine on d'auto
logis sages-femmes et pharmacie pour
celles et ceux qui optent pour la
médecine le deuxième cycle comprend des
cours théoriques mais aussi des cours
pratiques à l'hôpital
c'est seulement à la fin de la sixième
année de l'épreuve classantes nationales
que les étudiants pourront choisir leurs
spécialités et termineront leurs études
trois ou cinq ans après de longues
études qui n'effraie pourtant pas les
étudiants dans une ambiance de promo non
concert on sait qu'on va beaucoup tu as
fait on sait qu'on va en avoir pour
quelques années
du coup
du coup on y est préparé c'est quand on
voit nos autres amis qui sont dans
d'autres filières où l'on se rend compte
que dans quelques années ça fera cinq
six ans qu'on est dans des études et
confitures pas de smic déjà mais on n'y
pense pas trop en fait comme plus de 95
% des étudiants ici louise est titulaire
d'un bac scientifique
elle est en 4e année mon coeur a
beaucoup hésité entre faire une prépa
scientifique et partir en médecine et je
pense que c est le côté du soin et le
rapport à l'humain choisir la médecine
en première année il faut être motivé il
faut être moteur et il faut avoir aussi
une capacité ont capacité travail et de
mémorisation qui soit quand même assez
importante et ensuite dans les années
qui arrivent ensuite je pense pour être
un bon médecin même si c'est un peu je
mets des guillemets il faut il faut non
seulement avoir une grosse capacité de
travail mais aussi avoir des capacités
dans le relationnel est dans les mains
des choses qu'on vous apprend pas en
fait en cours et qui s'apprennent au fur
et à mesure de nos expériences
une formation qui demande de la rigueur
et beaucoup de travail personnel
chaque année seuls 25% des étudiants
passent le cap de la première année là
vous avez pu voir depuis le début de
cette émission que les métiers de la
science étaient donc nombreux et
demandez donc une formation bien
particulière alors voici ce qu'il faut
retenir pour être chercheur en physique
et travailler par exemple au laboratoire
national de métrologie et d'essai il
faut un doctorat il faudra ensuite
rédigé une thèse le salaire en début de
carrière environ 2000 euros nets
l'évolution possible être directeur
d'études gérer un projet et une équipe
la qualité indispensable avoir un
excellent niveau en anglais deuxième
métier dont il était question dans ce
numéro de mode d'emploi ingénieur
recherche et développement plusieurs
parcours sont possibles faire une école
d'ingénieurs ou bien un master à
l'université
la rémunération est comprise entre 2000
et 3000 euros nets en début de carrière
et selon l'entreprise
l'évolution possible à chef de projet
recherche et développement et puis le
petit plus pour ce métier est bien être
très curieuse alors maintenant si vous
êtes à la recherche d'un emploi et bien
un conseil prenez de quoi noter voici
aux offres proposées par l' agence pôle
emploi de guyancourt bonjour stéphane de
reims conseiller entreprises au pôle
emploi de guyancourt je vous parlais de
trois offres
la première le crazy hall qui est un
restaurant de plus de 1000 mètres carrés
à montigny-le-bretonneux qu'ils
recherchent pour l'ouverture de son
nouveautés que ouais vente à emporter
des employés polyvalents en temps plein
et temps partiel vous allez accueillir
les clients du restaurant coordonnées le
service à emporter
vous êtes le garant du bon déroulement
de la prise de commande jusqu'à
l'encaissement
vous êtes souriant polyvalent aimez le
travail en équipe
n'hésitez plus ouais postulait à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
la deuxième offre celle sur la société
savak 80 ans d'expérience dans le
transport de voyageurs
leader en ile de france il recrute 2
mécanicien poids lourds sur le site de
chevreuse vous effectuerez des travaux
d'électricité et d'entretien périodique
sur les véhicules
vous allez intervenir sur les organes
mécaniques diagnostiquer les pannes
effectuer des dépannages pour ça vous
avez bien évidemment le permis b et le
permis d serait un plus au moins 5 ans
d'expérience dans le domaine de la
mécanique
et si vous êtes mécanicien en véhicules
légers une formation interne est
possible et enfin la troisième offre
phone régie à guyancourt recrute pour
ses clients des hôtes et hôtesses
d'accueil standardistes sur vélizy saint
quentin et saclay vous allez gérer
l'accueil physique et téléphonique
jerry diverses tâches annexes comme
réservation de taxi gérer les salles de
réunion le courrier vous êtes dynamique
souriant polyvalent investi et adaptable
vous avez un esprit de service
vous parlez anglais rejoignez une
structure solide qui va vous proposer un
circuit d'intégration et de formation
et bien sûr si vous êtes une entreprise
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter et à nous
envoyer vos offres de recrutement à
l'adresse mail qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran redaction arobas tv 78 points
comme c'est bientôt la fin de ce mode
d'emploi mais avant et bien on va jeter
un rapide coup d'oeil
événements liés à l'emploi qui vous
attendent ce vendredi 27 octobre la cité
des métiers attrape organise des
ateliers d'orientation c'est à partir de
15 ans ce sera de 10 heures à 17 heures
l'inscription est obligatoire au 01 34
82 82 61
si vous êtes maintenant porteurs de
projets que vous souhaitez intégrer le
ski cube et bien l'incubateur de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lance un
nouvel appel à candidatures vous avez
jusqu'au 15 novembre pour faire votre
demande
ça se passe sur le site internet
www.skyrock.com slash ce cube
enfin jeudi 16 novembre la ville de
coignières organise la 15e journée de
recrutement
ce sera de 9h30 à 16h et cela se
déroulera dans les salons antoine de
saint-exupéry et si vous êtes une
entreprise et que vous avez des postes à
pourvoir et bien il ya encore des stands
de disponible pour plus de
renseignements un numéro de téléphone au
01 30 13 17 66 voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi 7 novembre pour un
nouveau numéro consacré cette fois ci
aux métiers du numérique à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]